today on the mattwell show performative
wokeness has reached epidemic levels in
this country and
it was on full display yesterday i'll
explain also we have our five headlines
of course including
some updates on that weird story of the
supposed right-wing plot to kidnap the
governor of michigan it appears
that this was more of an fbi plot which
the fbi then foiled
which was nice of them and prince harry
is once again showing how much he
desires privacy
by writing an explosive memoir about the
royal family while aoc
shows how much she hates capitalism by
investing heavily
in her online merchandise store in our
daily cancellation we'll talk about the
ladies of the us
women's soccer team who showed how much
they hate their own country by kneeling
before their match last night and then
they lost badly
which is hilarious all of that and more
today on the matte wall show
[Music]
before before we really get going today
i want to tell you about charity mobile
and this is going to something to keep
in mind
uh in what we're going to talk about in
the opening here because it really ties
back into it
uh when we've got all these woke
companies out there
that we all complained about all the
time and for good reason but
why complain about those companies or if
you're going to complain about those
companies
then you really should be supporting the
companies that support you
you know show show your support with
your money and charity mobile
is one of those companies they are the
pro-life phone company
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice uh and
this is all about
helping to build a culture of life in
america while supporting a pro-life
phone company
there aren't a lot of prolly phone
companies out there i think i think in
fact this is the only one so
um this is the place where you should be
spending your money with the phone
five percent of your monthly plan price
again goes to the pro-life fam uh
charity of your choice but also there
are a lot of other perks as well new
activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping there's no
contracts there's no termination fees
there's also no risk to you with a
30-day guarantee
and if you have any trouble at all any
problems then it's great that they've
got live customer service
based right in usa we're based right
here in the usa which means also
more american jobs that they're
providing and there's parental
controls too you can restrict cellular
data picture messages and text messages
on any and all of your accounts
so if you want to take advantage of this
great service you can call them at
1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
you may have noticed that we live in a
country a culture where almost everyone
wants to fashion themselves as heroes
and fighters for truth and justice and
yet their form of fighting
seems usually to require little effort
and it always amounts to nothing in the
end
this is one of the reasons why i'm not
worried about a civil war breaking out
any time soon
many people seem to be worried about
this and we hear uh there's gonna be a
civil war
we're headed towards a civil war civil
war yes we are
more divided than we've been since
1860 i think um you could make an
argument that we're even more divided
than we were
then in the lead up to the civil war on
a more fundamental level
but there will be no civil war because
fighting a civil war
requires us to leave our homes and put
down our video game controllers
and maybe even skip a meal or two this
is more commitment than
we're willing to invest in the
enterprise so instead our society will
come apart
more slowly decaying like an old
halloween pumpkin
left out in the sun rather than
exploding all at once
like fireworks so that's the good news
the perfect mascots for this
modern form of lazy bravery are of
course
the texas democrats who fled the state
in order to
temporarily avoid voting on some
legislation they disagree with
but in the midst of their boozy vacation
in dc at least six of the absconded
legislators
have tested positive for kovitt now what
was initially political theater
and an excuse for them to abandon their
kids and their loveless marriages for a
month
has now turned into a super spreader
event
which is what i think they call it right
you could argue that they're biological
terrorists at this point
and should be charged as such and thrown
in federal prison
you could argue that at least but even
as they drink miller light
take selfies and spread their viral
loads all over our nation's capital
like so much confetti they still wish to
be hailed for their bravery
and they're quite explicit about this
here's a tweet yesterday from
representative michelle beckley
she says my name is michelle beckley i'm
one of the brave texas democrats who
came to d.c to fight for voting rights
in my state
now i'm fighting to flip a seat a seat
held by an anti-democracy republican
i have 28 500 can you help us get to 50
000 followers
not only is she begging for followers
which is lame enough but she also calls
herself
brave perhaps the number one way that
you can identify a person who is not
brave
is if they have to tell you that they
are hi nice to meet you
um i am extremely brave yes deeply
courageous and heroic
no please don't shake my hand i'm afraid
of covet we can fist bump
but we're accustomed to this kind of
performative virtue signaling from our
politicians especially from democrats
after all democrats were the ones
who put on traditional african garb a
few months ago and
knelt in silence in the u.s capitol in
order to pay their respects to blessed
floyd patron saint of armed robbers
beckley's tweet was was nothing compared
to that as far as
theater goes um and virtue signaling
goes
and it's but it's not just politicians
who do this
we citizens are guilty ourselves
especially when it comes to the big
corporations
that most of us pretend to despise let's
take the events of yesterday for example
as we covered on the show jeff bezos
launched himself into space on a on a
rocket ship that he built with his own
money
um he returned to earth a short time
later much to the chagrin of many people
on social media who were
actively and vocally hoping that he'd
make it out of earth orbit and float off
into a black hole or something
the whole spectacle served as an
occasion for many people to once again
voice their hatred for bezos and and and
for
amazon and to lament the fact that he
has enough money to build rocket ships
in the first place
now as i said yesterday i i personally
think that it's a great thing for these
obscenely wealthy billionaires to spend
their money
on this that's my hot take that's my
controversial position
it is good for billionaires to be
building rocket ships
if it's a choice between building space
technology
or you know a 19 bedroom mansion for
their poodles
i'll take the space technology in fact i
wish
bezos had gotten back to earth and
immediately started building another
rocket
rather than do what he actually did
which was to immediately announce that
he was giving 100 million dollars to van
jones
why give a hundred million dollars to
van jones maybe the lack of oxygen in
space cause brain damage and that's why
he's doing it
or maybe the left hates bezos even as he
tries to buy them off
he is in the end a woke leftist himself
like nearly all of the other
tech oligarchs in his orbit literally
and figuratively in his orbit now
that doesn't stop most leftists from
hating him and his company just as many
on the right um
hate him as well the message seems to be
that bezos and amazon shouldn't have all
this money
it's not fair it's not right it's bad
how do you get all this money anyway it
must be a policy failure right yes
billionaires are a policy failure we're
told by bernie sanders and alexandria
caser cortez
yes government policy caused this we
need better policies
that's what made all this happen okay it
could be that
or it could be this headline from
marketwatch.com says
amazon prime member total reaches 142
million in the u.s
with more shoppers opting in for a full
year data shows
interestingly enough even as most people
seem to hate amazon
and wish that it didn't have all this
money to throw around most people are
also choosing to pay the company a
monthly subscription fee
in fact two-thirds of american adults
are amazon prime members
which is an insane figure
and those are just the members of the
service that doesn't count all the
people
who aren't members and yet still order
from amazon
i wonder if a single person complaining
about amazon and bezos
actually isn't one of their retail
customers
maybe there are a few but there can't be
many
so how did he get all that money um well
i don't know how to tell you this but
you gave it to him that's how he got it
he actually said this himself when he
got back to earth let's play that clip
i also i want to thank
every amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this so
seriously for every amazon customer out
there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart very much
people were very upset about that um and
it does come off as sort of uh
sarcastic and rubbing in everybody's
face but
it's true though that is actually true
we
as as amazon customers you paid for it
now we should acknowledge a few things
first
amazon was given a huge boost by the
government this past year talk about
policy failures
when many other cup many other stores
were arbitrarily shut down for reasons
that could never be scientifically or
morally justified
but this just adds to the contradiction
as most of the leftist
amazon haters were advocates for those
very policies and they accused you of
wanting to kill their grandmothers if
you suggested that hey you know
maybe we shouldn't just allow amazon and
walmart and target to be the ones
serving customers
and at any rate amazon had over 100
million subscribers a year before the
lockdowns even started
i doubt there were very very many people
who ordered from amazon for the first
time ever during the lockdowns maybe a
few but probably not many
the lockdowns gave amazon an enormously
unfair advantage
but they didn't turn amazon into the
ubiquitous force it is today obviously
also we should note that amazon makes
money other ways through other services
like it's amazon web services for
instance
but memberships and retail sales account
for the lion's share of its revenue
and that is revenue people choose
to give to it all kinds of excuses can
be
offered to get around this i've heard
them all people profess to hate the
company and think that it shouldn't have
all this money
and yet choose themselves to give it
their own money they can try to
rationalize it all they want they can
claim amazon is effectively a monopoly
in the online sales space
they can say that amazon offers services
other companies don't they can say that
you know they'd have to pay more or wait
longer to buy stuff another way
none of this gets around the fact or
rather around the choice
that they're making and do not have to
make
nobody needs amazon amazon is not a
necessity
indeed you could never order another
thing from amazon
ever again and that sacrifice would have
almost
no material impact on your life when all
is said and done
it would require from you only the
smallest of efforts only the most
minimal of investments
it would create only the most minor of
inconveniences
and yet that's more than most people are
willing to give they would prefer to
continue
actively funding this company while
complaining that the company should not
have the money
that they are choosing to give to it
maybe they really do oppose some of
amazon's business practices the way it
treats its workers the favors it gets
from the government so on
and they should they should hate those
things but they like convenient next day
delivery more than they hate those
things and that's the issue
the other thing i've heard talking about
rationalizations
as i was talking about this on on
twitter i i heard over and over again
this this same line and it comes from a
meme that you've probably seen
but uh the line is well yeah just
because i'm a critic of capitalism or
amazon that doesn't mean that i that i
that i can't participate in society
of course i have to participate in
society that phrase participating in
society
well yeah you're going to participate in
society but are you telling me that you
you need to use amazon in order to
participate in society you cannot
participate in society
without being an amazon prime member is
that really what you're telling me
none of what i'm saying amounts to a
defense of amazon and certainly not of
jeff bezos
i'm also not claiming to be innocent of
the charge that i'm leveling at others i
am guilty of choosing
to fund companies that i detest and
doing it simply for the sake of
convenience and maybe to save a buck or
two
i've drawn certain lines and i've tried
to avoid drawing others
this is uh the game we all play we are
consumers
so conditioned in our consumerism that
so many of us would actually claim as
people have claimed to me
that ordering junk from amazon is a need
like water and shelter are needs
but it's not a need it's a want
and we are very bad at distinguishing
between the two
and that ultimately i think is the
problem
now let's get to our five headlines
i think there are many things you could
do as an american to celebrate
and uh show how much you appreciate
your your freedom as an american one of
those things though
is grow a thick manly beard i don't mean
to exclude
women when i say this and this goes for
women too i mean you could also grow
anyone can anyone can try anyway to grow
that thick beard if you're one of
the men that are currently growing or
already have a manly beard chances are
you're in need of products to keep it
looking thick and healthy
and if so you gotta visit
beardsupply.com because for a limited
time
you can buy one beard oil product and
get another one for free
this is a great deal on an already
affordable top quality product
there there are tons of different beard
oils and everything out there it can
kind of get kind of overwhelming if you
go to the store
and uh they're not all made equal trust
me okay
this is what this is i don't know a lot
but i i know about beards and beard oil
beard supply they make a top quality
product so go visit our friends over at
beardsupply.com today
and order yourself two beard oils for
the price of one you can mix and match
different scents or stock up on old
classics
whatever you choose make sure you choose
beard supply for a limited time
make sure you go to beardsupply.com and
buy one beard oil and get another one
for free
um all right you know first of all you
guys know that i i don't like to air my
dirty laundry on this show
it's too dark and cold in the studio
anyway so get mildo mildew
that was a dad joke i apologize for that
anyway the point is
um i don't like to talk about my
personal problems except when i talk
about them all the time
but i do have to say i'm disturbed by
my wife's bigotry towards me as a
disabled american
especially when she publicizes it as she
often does
on twitter this is what she tweeted last
night when i was sitting right across
the room from her by the way
a couple days ago when she tweeted this
um i'm concerned about matt walsh's
outfit tomorrow
he said well she tagged my user she
wasn't calling me by my full name that
would be weird
i'm concerned about matt's outfit
tomorrow he said what's what's wrong
with red
pants and a green top well one that
combo would make him look like an elf
and two he's colorblind and the pants
are brown and the polo is a lighter
green making him look like peter pan or
a tree
now first of all to clarify the only
reason we were talking about my outfit
is that i
asked her to iron my clothes for me and
the only reason i asked her to do that
is because i'm bad at ironing and i've
explained
there are a lot of household chores i'm
just not good at and i need other people
to do them for me
but then she starts mocking my choices
calling me a tree and peter pan and
everything
when in fact i really am colorblind this
is this is an important point i want you
all to know i am actually colorblind
um in fact i am a member of the the
color
vision deficiency community that's the
that is that is the real thing we're
going by now cvd
color vision deficiency and this is a
real
victim group that i belong to i am an
actual victim
i suffer from a disability
which means that it's hate speech to be
credited to be mocking me for it
and and also i i i cling to this
identity jealously it's the only victim
group i have
as a as a white male none others are
recognized
in the mainstream culture but this one i
have
and i want all you to know that
before you think about criticizing me at
all realize i am a victim i am
colorblind
i have no idea so it and that's another
thing i am i am often mocked
on my own show by my own audience for
the things that i choose to wear on this
show
maybe you'll mock me i don't know what
color this is i don't even know what i'm
wearing right now
but before you start criticizing me just
know i have no idea this is this is part
of my disability
right uh we'll start with this the daily
mail
actually was uh buzzfeed originally
buzzfeed doing some real reporting which
they they've they've done
a little bit of that recently i don't
know if i i don't want to
get ahead of my get over my skis here
but but
it seems like they they're kind of
dipping their toes in real reporting and
so they're doing some real reporting
here
um and it's information about that
supposed right-wing plot to cup to
kidnap governor whitmer of michigan you
may remember that
and this was governor whitmer
was was one of the the primary one of
the worst most oppressive
pettiest most arbitrary tyrants during
the coveted lockdowns
she went insane with power couldn't
handle
she thought originally she was just
going to be governor of michigan that'd
be enough power
but then she was given the powers of an
empress and
um you know a dictator
and she couldn't handle it having that
much power
she fell in love with it speaking of
clinging desperately to things clinging
desperately to that power
and getting getting a lot of uh pushback
for that have become pretty unpopular
and then in the midst of that we find
out that uh there were these
dastardly right-wingers who were
planning to
kidnap her um
and and and then and then that kind of
made it okay well now you're not allowed
to criticize her anymore
because all of this criticism like i
just was calling her a dictator well
your feet is this hate speech and you're
encouraging violence look at what you've
done that's the kind of way this was
this was a spun but now this and i'm
reading from uh
the daily mail says the fbi has been
accused of encouraging an ins
and assisting a michigan militia with
their alleged plot to kidnap governor
gretchen whitmer
with court documents showing the
remarkable depth of involvement of
multiple informants
okay so listen to this
14 people have been charged so far after
an october 2020 sting operation on the
wolverine watchman militia
many of those were arrested at a
warehouse of michigan where they had met
to hand over cash for the purchase of
explosives which they allege allegedly
planned to use in the kidnapping plot
in december one key player in the case
ty garbin
entered a guilty plea to kidnap
conspiracy charges and faces up to life
in prison
a trial date for the rest has been set
for october 12th
but their lawyers are arguing that the
fbi informants at least
12 of them according to a buzzfeed
investigation
went way beyond simply listening and
infiltrating and instead
actively recruited others to the plot
funded and directed it
they have claimed that without the fbi
informant's involvement there would have
been no plot at all
okay so 14 people if i'm if i'm getting
my numbers right if
i'm reading this correctly 14 people
have so
so far been charged um
as being involved in this scheme 12
people were fbi informants the whole
time
and it makes you wonder as as more and
more of this comes out
is were any of them not fbi informants
was it just like one maybe this this
thai garbage guy was he the only was it
one guy
was it 13 fbi informants ganging up to
just get this one guy
i don't know
and it's it's not as though based on the
claim here allegedly
based on this report from buzzfeed it
would seem that
um that it's it's not as though
they had come up with this plot and the
fbi got wind of it and then they sent in
some
informants to try to stop it
the informants again according to the
buzzfeed investigation the informants
themselves
were the ones who recruited people into
it funded it
directed it so what it was their plot
what i'm getting from this is that this
kidnapping plot was the fbi's plot they
are the ones who
who organized it put it all together
and then they stopped it
so i guess in the end we should uh we
should congratulate the fbi and thank
the fbi
for putting a stop to the dastardly plot
that they came up with
kind of easy to stop a plot that is your
own plot
but i'm but i'm grateful that they did
stop it true heroes in the fbi once
again
and it makes you wonder too and we know
this is something that the fbi does
um not just sending people in undercover
not just having informants but
toeing the line of entrapment or or
outright
committing outright entrapment which is
what this seems to be
we know the fbi has a habit of that um
historically
uh you start to wonder about the events
of january 6th are we going to find
we're going to find out similar they're
going to be similar revelations
a year from now or so about what
happened on january 6th
the ringleaders of that the people who
put all that together
i guess we'll see or maybe we never will
see
next a report from reuters um this is
kind of some real journalism also so big
i'm
i continue to be shocked uh this is a
maybe a good day for mainstream
journalists they don't have very many
but here's one
uh some reuters reports u.s
representative alexandria quezo cortez
became one of america's most prominent
progressive democrats with her calls to
tax the wealthy
and spend heavily to fight climate
change now she is investing heavily in
her online store selling t-shirts
sweatshirts
and other merchandise with her name aoc
initials or slogans including tax the
rich
and fight for our future efforts aimed
at both fundraising and building the
second term lawmakers profile nationally
her campaign paid political merchandise
firm financial innovations
which operates her online store and
supplies merchandise more than 1.4
million dollars in the first six months
of 2021
according to campaign disclosures to the
fec late last week
that's more than many lawmakers spent on
their entire re-election effort during
that period
and nearly double her payments made over
the prior two years to financial
innovations
um a cranston rhode island firm that
specializes in political merchandise for
democrats political t-shirts campaign
swag where once again uh
yeah okay so i think we get the idea
there she's
spending one and a half million dollars
investing in merchandise that she's
then gonna sell including merchandise
that ironically says tax the rich
now sean spicer pointed this out
former white house spokesman now a
newsmax host
pointed this out on twitter and aoc
responded it pointed out the
the hypocrisy here that you're a critic
of capitalism
you're socialists vowedly so and
here you are engaging in capitalism
what do you know turns out you actually
like making money
you just don't like it when other people
make it you want to be the one who makes
it
aoc responded to the criticism though
and said not sure if you know this sean
but transactions aren't capitalism
capitalism is a system that prioritizes
profit at
any and all human slash environmental
cost
but for what it's worth our shop is
unionized doesn't operate for profit and
funds projects like free tutoring food
programs
and local organizing okay so
so so that's what it is
yeah i would have thought that if you're
in in the free market making a
transaction with somebody else
offering them a good or service in
exchange for money that's a transaction
i would have thought no that's exactly
what capitalism is actually
that's at the most basic level that's
free market capitalism i have a go to
good or service
i offer it to you you choose to buy it
with your own money
i take your money i have it now
that i'm no economist but when i think
of
at the most basic level what a free
market capitalism is that's that's what
it is
but she says no no no no no so you can
do that and it's not capitalism because
capitalism
uh is a system sort of like that but it
prioritizes profit
at any and all human and environmental
cost
so she's saying i am i am making a
profit but it but it's
it's i'm not prioritizing that over
everything else
it's only if you prioritize it over
everything else that counts as
capitalism
which is just a long way of saying it
all goes back to
i can do this but i don't think other
people should
i can trust myself with money
my own money your money
which i should be given whether it's
because you're buying a t-shirt or i
just take it from you
[Music]
i'm a good person i can be trusted with
money not the rest of you because you're
bad people
uh next number three here page six
reports that prince harry
is writing an explosive memoir about his
life and the royal family uh
so he's got another he's got this i
guess this is
maybe this is his first memoir that he's
written
and this is so sad you know he's writing
this this big memoir
he's got a big book deal he's got he's
gonna have the book coming out talking
about his life talking about the expose
about the royal family
um he's going to be doing the book tour
doing more and more interviews and it is
so so sad
um because this poor man and his wife
they just want privacy that's all they
want will you people leave them alone
and let them have their private life
please that's all they want
that's why he's putting the book out and
he does the oprah interview
and they got the netflix deal
this this is their way of of living a
private life
and you should respect that
i guess by not buying the book that's
maybe the best thing you can do i think
that's the best thing you could do
in general why would you want this damn
book
why would you want to read it but
i i i think out of out of pure respect
for the wishes that have been repeatedly
articulated by prince harry and megan
in many in many many interviews
for privacy and to be left alone out of
respect for that
you should not buy any of the these
books not watch any of these stupid
interviews
um not watch any show that they produce
it's what they want i guess they want
what they want is
is is they want to write the books and
not have anyone read it
they want to do the netflix show and not
have anyone watch it
they want to do the oprah interviews and
not have anyone watch that either or
hear about it
and i for one will respect their wishes
on that front i hope they'll do the same
uh we also got to play this rand paul
and dr fauci had another had another
sparring match and these are always fun
to watch it's fun to watch fauci
this is the only time it's why you get
so upset when this happens
it's the only time when fauci is
backed into a corner forced to answer
real questions
held accountable it's the only time
because everywhere else he goes
people are worshiping the ground he
walks on he does a cn interview cnn
interviews he does the msnbc interviews
and they are head over heels in love
with him
practically making out with him on
screen
um and uh
the one time where that doesn't happen
is when he's facing congress and only
because rand paul is there it wasn't for
rand paul
you know these would also be make out
sessions but
uh let's let's watch how this went if
the point
that you are making is that the the
grant
that was funded as a sub award from eco
health
to wuhan created sars kovi 2.
that's where you are getting let me
finish we don't know
wait a minute but all the evidence is
pointing that it came from the lab
and there will be responsibility for
those who funded the lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to
i totally resent the lie that you are
now propagating
senator because if you look at the
viruses
that were used in the experiments
that were given in the annual reports
that were published in the literature it
is
molecularly impossible no one's saying
that
it is caused it is molecularly those
virus caused the pandemic what we're
alleging
is the gain of function research was
going on in that lab
and nih funded it that is get away from
it meets your
definition and you are obfuscating the
truth and you are implying
that what we did was responsible for the
deaths of individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying
here senator it is you
i resent that i resent it uh
what he's saying is is he is lying that
fouchy that is
this is this all goes back to the issue
of did the nih fund gain of function
research in wuhan and uh and it did and
that's a fact and it did
um and fauci totally resents
that he's being asked about this that
he's being held to account for it
totally resents it now when this is a
big scandal this is like a big deal
they're funding this kind of research in
this lab
which was almost certainly the the
origin of this uh global pandemic that
killed so many people
but he doesn't he shouldn't have to talk
about it and he knows
you got to almost feel for the guy i
guess that yeah everywhere else he goes
everyone is uh
is is bowing down before him
and it's this one guy who won't do that
rand paul
i guess you don't have to feel for him
at all um rand paul though
a lot of credits ramp i mean if rand
paul wasn't there
he's he's seriously he's the one
lawmaker holding
the fouchy accountable to his face
all right i've had this story for a few
days now i keep meaning to mention it
because it's so important it's from the
daily wire it says after being called
out for her inconsistent spanish accent
and apparently misleading the public
about her spanish heritage
hilaria or hillary more actually baldwin
now says she identifies as culturally
fluid
seemingly arguing that she can be
culturally fluid if others can be
sexually religious and politically fluid
too
she posted to instagram recently when
you are multi
it can feel very hard to belong you're
constantly going back and forth trying
to be more this or more that
you feel you have to explain why you are
the way you are trying to fit into a
world of labels where
there might not be one that perfectly
defines you you will never quite fit in
because other parts of you shape and
influence all of your parts
we need to normalize the fact that we
are all unique our language culture
sexual orientations religions political
beliefs are allowed to be fluid
no two of us are completely alike
and uh this is not good enough for
lots of people especially on the left
who
are kind of mocking this idea of being
culturally fluid
when of course if anything can be fluid
that actually makes some kind of sense
that they're they're certainly it
doesn't make some kind of it makes sense
uh there is a fluidity to culture
there's no denying that
cultures change over time um our culture
has changed quite a bit and not for the
better
cultures change over time they influence
each other uh
one culture kind of bleeds into another
they blend they mix
if the word fluid has any meaning
outside of
outside of the physical sense of liquid
fluid um then this would have to apply
cultures are fluid they're not
immutable they don't
they don't stay the same forever
they're not inherent um
they're human constructs all of that is
true of culture
now and i i i don't mean that to suggest
that uh that that you know we shouldn't
want to
protect our culture and defend it
and try to make it a certain thing and
protect it from other kinds of
influences
but i'm just talking about the nature of
of culture
as opposed to uh your sex
which is not fluid at all which is
inherent which is not it which is not a
human construct
which you don't determine
does not blend with anything else just
you are what you are
so in our own extremely stupid culture
the one thing that
is fluid you're not allowed to say is
fluid and then all these other things
of course those are the things we're
going to pretend are fluid speaking of
which
um here's a here's a video i want to
play for you
before we get to reading the youtube
comments you know my
my famous question that i'm asking all
the time related to what we were just
talking about
which is what is a woman and for years
i've been asking that question
have never received an answer to it what
we'll play for you now
is is not an answer it's a non-answer
but at least she knows that she's giving
a non-answer
and so i feel like there's a little bit
of progress just based on that alone
let's listen
okay can someone help me out with this
because i'm confusing i am a woman i
identify as a woman i feel comfortable
in being a woman like
what the woman like if someone asked me
what does being a woman mean to you i
wouldn't have an answer don't even try
to tell me that well being a woman is
being empathetic and kind and
compassionate because that could be
anybody
anybody could be those things don't even
bother being transphobic in my comments
saying that oh well being a woman is
having a uterus and having kids
because no no don't even bother
saying that being a woman means having
bitties and having a vagine because
no also no wrong so i'll ask the
question again
what is a woman like i feel so
comfortable identifying as a woman but
is that only because that's just what
i've always been
that's what people always told me that i
was so i just went with it and the thing
that's frustrating with this question is
that everyone's answer is always
well it depends on the person and i get
that i know but i'm trying to figure it
out for myself and i don't know and i
mean i'm a gender abolitionist so like
abolish gender you know but some people
feel very validated in their labels and
in their gender so i'm strictly speaking
for myself i don't know what being a
woman means to me anyone else
uh yeah well that's the question
isn't it what the f is a woman
as she as she phrases not how i phrase
it that's how that's how she phrases it
can anyone answer the question well i
can
a woman is an adult human female i have
no trouble answering it
but she at least she has no answer
but she's one of the only people that
i've seen so far that will acknowledge
that they don't have an answer and that
this is a problem
so she knows that at least
if maybe that if i want to be optimistic
maybe that'll plant a seed in her head
it's like at least you're thinking about
it
and that's step one
and that's that's that's more of a step
than lots of people are willing to take
in general not most people aren't
willing to think about anything really
but she realizes there's a problem here
she says i'm a woman uh
i know who and what i am and yet i have
this ideology and my
and my and my politics which would say
that
uh that my womanhood has nothing to do
with my body it also has nothing to do
with any of my
preferences or personality traits
because if you say that being a woman is
determined by my body that's transphobic
don't be transphobic but if you say that
it all has to do with being feminine and
being
and you know acting in a quote-unquote
womanly way well that's anti-feminist
and we can't by be anti-feminist so
we're left with no
no definition at all this is a big
problem
she realizes that it's a big problem
she's saying that i that i'm a i'm a
woman but i don't even i can't tell i
don't know what that is
you're right it is a problem and i have
to tell you something
young lady uh there is there is no way
around it
if you're insisting on clinging on to
your
self-contradictory delusional
ideological and political beliefs which
are really more
like religious beliefs as long as you
hang on to that doctrine there is
there's no way around this conflict
you're going to be doomed to live this
life with an identity that you can't
define
with an identity that that according to
you doesn't exist
no way around it
the only way is to let go of that
doctrine
which you can let go of and it's it's
freedom
because rather than having all of these
uh different
contradictory balls that you're trying
to juggle in the air
an unfortunate metaphor there for a
number of reasons but still rather than
trying to
juggle all of these these balls what you
can do is you can drop
them this is getting more and more
unfortunate as we talk about
uh but you can you can drop them and say
i don't i don't need to do this
i don't need to make this work with that
how do i be uh you know feminist but
also
not trans forget about that you can
embrace who you are
you're a woman at and when it comes down
to a deep down i think you
you actually do know what that means
because you know who you are
and that's a good thing let go of the
delusion let go of the doctrine
let go of those balls and just be who
you are
all right read the youtube comments now
uh and as we do if you're wondering what
reading through
if you're watching through the bicep cam
that is our little astronaut here
is wearing the sweet baby gang t-shirt
so we got one for the miniature
astronaut we don't have one yet
for you although the sweet baby gang
petition is now up to
1200 1219 so over 1200 signatures
we got you know almost we got 281 to go
before the next threshold that's when
we'll be at 1 500
signatures on the change.org petition to
get these sweet baby gang t-shirts on
sale
i don't know what's supposed to happen
at 1 500 but
let's get there anyway in this
grassroots movement
all right um username mostly peaceful
says
talking about my opening monologue
yesterday this was impressively stupid
this country has thousands of immoral
and tyrannical laws
this is what counts as conservative
these days someone who thinks the
government should
force us to do what they think is moral
sounds like a leftist
well mostly peaceful it sounds like you
uh
speaking of stupid it sounds like you
were not
paying attention to anything i said
you were paying attention enough to pick
up on a few words and phrases here and
there
but my basic argument you completely
missed somehow
which i don't know how you managed to
miss an argument that i make because i
repeat myself so much i'm sure you've
noticed
because i want it to be understood i'll
keep repeating it and repeating it
my when i talk about how all laws
are moral laws every law that's ever
been written
is a moral law you cannot have a law
that is not a moral law or at least
to try to imagine a a in a non-moral law
is is an absurdity it would be it would
be what you would end up with is a
totally
arbitrary law that has no reason to
exist
so maybe you can imagine one but you but
uh
you certainly wouldn't want a law like
that to actually be passed
um but when i say that all laws are
moral laws
it doesn't mean that they're the correct
morals it doesn't mean i agree
okay you can make a moral argument for
something
somebody could make a moral argument
like i said yesterday
somebody can make a moral argument for
for abortion you can make a moral
argument for abortion
that doesn't mean it's a good argument
and it's not a good argument
but all it me all that means is that you
are using you're trying to use
morals you're up you're using a moral
appeal
you're appealing to our moral sense in
order to advocate for abortion in that
case
to acknowledge that that's what you're
doing is not to agree with
the argument you're making and so
every law at base is is a moral law
it doesn't mean they're good yes
oftentimes they're tyrannical
they're immoral they're evil
but still there is a moral argument at
the bottom
and the whoever introduced that law
advocated it
legislated it imposed it whatever
whatever person or group is responsible
for that law
it's guaranteed that they were making a
moral argument to justify it might have
been a bad argument
might have been a horrific argument but
it was a moral argument
is that is that enough
it that seems to me in my own ears to be
understandable
and coherent so hopefully now you get
what i was saying uh
resident wiseacre says 25 years ago
someone who spent all day in the library
was called a scholar today they're
called homeless
well that is that is i suppose a correct
observation
which is a shame now i used to be a big
fan of libraries but the other thing is
the libraries are
everything is it's it sounds silly to
even say what i'm going to say but i
have to
libraries are politicized everything is
politicized now libraries too
where they're bringing in you know drag
queens story hours and everything
um abby taylor says if matt reads this
comment on the show i'll pre-order ben's
book and in my question i'll ask if matt
can sign it instead of ben
and address it to the sweet baby gang
well i read your comments so
get to work this is a win-win for
everybody i helped sell another copy of
ben's book
and maybe he promotes the sweet baby
gang i i
i doubt that that will happen but
let's give it a shot it's worth a shot
um
bob says wow matt any more obvious
you're trying to get a ticket for
bezos's next trip
maybe on his lap aha ban me i'll just
keep watching
uh well you are banned of course but no
i
that's actually the last thing i would
want i i don't want to get in the rocket
ship i'm fascinated by space
by the idea of it uh as i've been saying
i i love the idea of people building
rocket ships and going up in space i
think oh that's great
i don't want to do it i would be way too
terrified to actually do
i don't like getting on an airplane
you know and flying from nashville to
baltimore right on a
two-hour plane trip so going 50 miles in
the sky or higher
is not uh not my cup of tea although
that's that's not as bad i i read a
story yesterday
as we're all these different companies
are getting in trying to get into the
burgeoning
space tourism industry which of course
burgeoning
among multi-millionaires and
billionaires the only ones who can
afford it right now
but there's one company they're looking
at at doing these space trips
in a space balloon which is like a
massive high-tech hot air balloon the
size of a football field
and you would drift up into space on one
of those that to me is it
that fills me with so much existential
dread to even think of doing something
like that
so no thank you but i'm glad people are
doing it
just like i'm i'm not going to be on the
trip getting on a
on a ship to go to mars
but i like the idea of people doing that
especially certain people if i could
select the people and send them to mars
it'd be even better i got a lot of
people in mind who i would like to send
and aoc zaboylo says let there be a
competition
for the best sweet baby gang song i
think that's an excellent idea
make your own sweet baby gang song post
it to youtube
and i'll play them on the show let's and
if you can if you do
and you already know if you do one with
a banjo
you get you get extra credit you know
while some people
see npr's latest smear campaign that's
been waged against the daily wire as an
attempt at bringing the thought police
to our doorstep
doorstep i think there's another way you
can look at it as well the entire
article talks about our success
as a news organization and was published
the same day
that we dropped our newest podcast
morning wire which is already ranked at
the top of the apple charts and steadily
climbing even higher
because our listeners know morning wire
is the morning podcast that values their
time and the truth
brought to you by daily wire editor in
chief john bickley and co-host georgia
howe morningwire will wake you up with
the latest developments in politics
sports culture and education all
with a heavy emphasis on the facts
because that's what you need when it
comes to when it comes to the news
what you probably really want most of
all just tell me the facts it's
available now so subscribe to
morning wire and apple podcast spotify
and everywhere you listen to podcasts so
you don't miss
a beat you also don't want to miss ben
shapiro's new book when it comes to
freedom america
is the world's last hope with lockdown
protests getting increasingly violent in
london citizens and business owners
facing prison time
for disobeying vaccine passport laws in
france it's become increasingly clear
that we have to fight to keep
the last free country actually free and
that means standing up to the bind
administration's new call for censorship
across all platforms
um or as they're calling it
misinformation it perfectly illustrates
what ben shapiro predicted in his newest
book the authoritarian moment
which is hitting bookshelves next
tuesday july 27th you don't want to miss
out on this you also want to miss
when ben will be doing a live stream
book signing event next tuesday the 27th
so pre-order your signed copy now
and when you do you'll be asked to type
in a question at checkout
then catch tuesday's live signing to see
if he answers your question and watch
him sign your book
go get a copy now at dailywire.com ben
and let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we
begin with some good news for a change
the philadelphia inquirer has the story
it says the u.s women's soccer team
opened the olympics in disastrous
fashion losing 3-0 to long-time rival
sweden
it was the program's worst defeat at a
major tournament since 2007
and manager vladko andanovsky's first
loss since taking a helm in october 2019
and it was no fluke it was an
honest-to-goodness beating for all the
talk of the us being the tournament's
heavy favorite
sweden was on the front foot from the
start and rarely let up
i don't really know what that means they
outshot the americans by 16-13 in the
game including by 10-3 in the first half
an american
team loaded with past medals but also
the oldest squad in this tournament
looked the latter more than the former
now from what i'm hearing this is was
almost as embarrassing as the time when
they lost to a bunch of adolescent boys
it's almost it's also almost as
hilarious and wonderful but not quite
i'm not ashamed to tell you that i am
actively rooting against u.s women's
soccer i want them to lose
i want them to be embarrassed badly on
the global stage
because they have so thoroughly and
intentionally embarrassed us
the daily mail reports quote the us and
the us
and team gb women's football teams were
among those who
took the knee took the knee ahead of
their opening matches in the olympics
today all
22 players took part in the gesture
prior to kickoff between four-time
olympics champion
the u.s and sweden and tokyo an hour
after team gb and chile did likewise
in sapporo the ioc recently relaxed the
rules for protests at the game softening
a long-standing ban on political
protests at the global sporting event
athletes will now be allowed to take a
knee before play begins to highlight
racial injustice
speak to the media and post online about
their views or wear clothing with a
protest slogan at a press conference
so u.s women's soccer took the knee as
always
none of them could explain why they're
kneeling none of these people
have ever been able to offer any cogent
explanation as to what exactly they're
protesting
and that's because they aren't
protesting any particular thing so much
as expressing a general disdain for
their country
and this stunt comes as no surprise
either these are the same ladies who
wore blm shirts while also taking a knee
during the anthem before a game last
year led by political activist megan
rapido
they have consistently put their
politics front and center and declined
to display patriotism in favor in favor
of this sort of woke virtue signaling
all while repeatedly declaring their
allegiance with an organization blm
that is among the most destructive evil
and depraved
to exist in this country in modern
history
these women are not interested in
representing the united states
they want to represent their own
ideological interests they've shown
no pride in their country no allegiance
to it and so i have no pride in them
i want them to lose that's what they
deserve
it's true of course that the other women
from the other teams knelt also
um one set of kneelers losing just means
another set wins unfortunately
but those other women are not supposed
to be representing our country
it's not our country that they make a
mockery of if some morons from sweden
want anneal that's sweden is concerned
if morons from the u.s kneel
it's ours this is where we are now and
it's not where i want to be
even though i'm only vaguely interested
in the olympics and i'm not at all
interested in soccer
i still want to root for our teams and
our players
but if you won't stand and show pride in
your country if patriotism is too much
to ask for
if this country has blessed you beyond
measure and still you put your
allegiance to violent marxist
organizations like blm
over your allegiance to the flag then i
am ashamed
to share a country with you and i don't
think you deserve to represent us in
front of the globe
you know there's a lot of gaslighting
that's gone on with this issue of course
those of us who feel this way about it
those of us who are sick to death of the
political statements the kneeling and so
on
we're accused of being the ones to
politicize sports
and if we celebrate the defeat of
athletes who carry on this way
we're accused of being disloyal but
we're not the ones who chose to make
sports into an ideological
battlefield and what we're asking for is
not much
it really isn't all we want
is for these people to conduct
themselves with a little dignity
and to display just the faintest hint of
gratitude for the country that they live
in and represent
and which has given them so much
if that's too much to ask for
then it's too much to ask us to root for
you
i hope you fail and i'm glad when you do
and also you're canceled will leave it
there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day everyone
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show jeff bezos
travels to space
and redistributionists are fighting mad
about it plus rand paul and anthony
fauci
go mono imano that's today on the ben
shapiro we'll talk about all of it